we're the cast of One Piece and today we
have to answer 50 of the most asked
questions about the show why are we
waiting for I had to do whatever
what is the one piece it's supposed to
be the greatest treasure in the world
and he left it all in one piece but we
don't know and maybe it's nothing my
theory is that the one piece must be a
taco it only makes sense right it's the
greatest treasure in the world why are
they called the straw hat Pirates Luffy
is our captain he wears a straw hat and
we are the straw hat Pirates what is the
straw hat Pirates ship when at first it
is the going Mary
[Music]
Thousand Sunny what do all the straw hat
Pirates do on the ship okay okay so I
think on a normal day in the go and
marry Luffy he steals food from the
kitchen oh way cute this is totally not
what I thought we were just gonna say
like our jobs but I love you I love you
guys to like
Nami is the navigator on the ship I look
for the best spots to on the ship to
sleep take a nap right hand man but
first it made whatever I want usapa
takes care of the ship and I'm the cook
how does Monkey D Luffy's ability work
I'm a rubber man I I just throw punches
and it hits what is a devil fruit my
character Luffy he ate a fruit which is
a devil fruit and it gave him Powers
there's a lot of different types of
devil fruits uh the one that Luffy ate
is the gum gum fruit which made him a
rubber man but the thing about devil
fruits is that it makes that the seed
turns its back against you so you cannot
swim and you sink immediately so that's
why they're devil fruits I guess it's
like making a deal with the devil you
get powers but you cannot swim how does
real nor Zorro fight with three swords
one in his mouth
those nami's tattoo represent first one
one is uh our long second one is the
pinwheel and also the Tangerine so it's
a representation of her family and her
home who is gold D Roger who started
everything he's the one who declared
that the one piece is out there and set
everybody out on a mission to find it
yeah some people might really like him
well Fame power yes what's the
significance of the letter D the will of
D the will of D Luffy I got his dad
you've got Garb it's all these people
have a very
strong arguably unbreakable will and
power it's a mystery maybe it stands for
dreamers or Donuts what are the names of
all the oceans in one piece East blue
West Blue North Blue South Blue what is
the grand line I think our resident map
reader would be the most
exact same person
the grand line is a treacherous stretch
of ocean filled with bigger Pirates
bigger monsters ripe with riches and
like ready for the picking or something
like that
who are the seven Warlords of the sea
pirates that the Marines sanctioned to
help do the things that Marines can't do
pirate mercenaries basically so I know a
few mihawk uh crocodile well uh
that's right crocodile gym Bay
comoria Boa Hancock or dilakuma maybe
you guys can answer what's acceptable
Flamingo I cannot remember the flamingo
yes oh who is yesel who is yes who is
yasu I'm always someone would tell me
about my daddy
yasup is uh usopp's father he's a
marksman he's a sniper uh it's
definitely part of why USA wants to go
out and be a brave Warrior how does the
ship travel underwater so they do
something called coding on the Thousand
Sunny so that it can go underwater it's
like a bubble yeah yeah
the going merry fly yes yeah yeah with a
little with a little adjustments it's a
magical ship it can do anything that's
my baby she fly who is stronger than
gold D Roger I know this one actually
maybe rocks rocks rocks be Civic I think
it's subjective is Usopp a god wow what
I don't even know how to answer that
question he's not I don't know he's not
he's not a god he's not but but
he doesn't yeah he doesn't he does some
god-like things you know who is the
creator of one piece
I don't know oh no it was like don't
even know yeah
himself he created one piece in 1997
when he was like 17 years old no he's so
young he's like one of the best like
storytellers of her time why did buggy
get so big and he did get big it's for
show though he's just using the chop
chop fruit to make him a really big like
cloak he looks like a tick it's more
about he has insecurity issues yeah
buggy if you're listening bro we love
you man we love you as you are why is
one piece so popular it's like saying
why is the Bible so popular
[Applause]
who is Yamato oh she's from wano she's
from Moana and she's kaido's daughter
this has been something I've been like
reading on Twitter because there's such
a massive discourse is Yamato a girl is
Yamato a boy because I in the manga they
use male pronouns but then at there's a
certain point where they say oh it's
kaido's daughter Yamato is a very
powerful hockey user ice powers also
yeah is Jimmy a member of the straw hat
Pirates Jean Bay technically yes he
didn't officially join he's not on the
ship with them but I do believe that
they've said that he's an honorary
member who are the main Admirals in one
piece okiji
they usually have three main Admirals
but of course as the story goes on those
change people get their asses handed to
them who are the four Emperors Shanks
buggies one right buggy buggy Blackbeard
and uh a certain somebody who could the
who could the fourth one be I wonder who
could it be I guess we'll find out
what is a Fishman it's a fish God
essentially yes half man half fish is it
half and half quite explicitly I feel
like it could be seven I don't think
it's it's not in the sense of like there
was one human and one fish and well I
don't even want to talk
it's like a if a human could breathe
underwater and swim really fast and like
at Scales where is Monkey D Luffy from
he's from Windmill Village which isn't
the East blue who gave Monkey D Luffy
his hat red-haired Shanks the coolest
pirate ever he was in Windmill Village
and he became very close to Luffy and
before he left to continue his
adventures he gave him his most valuable
treasure his straw hat and Luffy's takes
care of that straw hat with his life and
he promised the shanks that he will give
it back to him one day once he has
become a great pirate what is the one
rule Sanji will never break never waste
food I mean he's got he's a pretty
disciplined dude he has he has a lot of
rules I think never waste food is at the
top of the list all right
speed round it what is nami's dream to
draw a map of the world do usup's Lies
come true every time where this road and
Noah Zorro get these swords the most
famous sword uhmunji from a father of
his childhood friend and rival queena
who are Monkey D Luffy's parents uh
Monkey D dragon and unknown how did
these teacher lose his leg he ate it our
sniper king and usop the same person
D Luffy there are many voice actors for
Luffy in different languages
she has been voicing Luffy the longest
since 1999. she is an amazing amazing
actress where does Sanji work uh what
point
um
then with the straw hat crew what is
Zero's dream to be the world's greatest
Swordsman
who is the most wanted man oh that is
Monkey D drive yeah Sanji stream finally
all blue what is the name of Luffy's
brother
yes where's the strongest swordsman in
one piece besides obviously sorrow why
is Frankie a cyborg well he had to be
before the celestial dragons uh I think
they're like descendants of like the
people who the celestial dragons were
the people who ended up being the world
government how many one-piece episodes
are there I guess this is subjective to
when you see this video but right now in
this car moment
uh 1065. does Frankie have a devil fruit
dude no he was offered one he wasn't
hungry what devil fruit did Chopper eat
human human fruit
what are the three different types of
devil fruit paramecia Sohan and Logan
the Nokia why does Nami love money
because money is great
next question next question
who is stronger Sanji ozaro let's not
oh it's not working here all day all
I'll say is I don't need any external
weapons
this is really fun well we have no more
questions
we did it that's it thank you for
watching
that was so satisfying